afternoon everyone and welcome my
colleagues at the Federal Reserve and I
are dedicated to serving the American
people we do this by steadfastly
pursuing the goals Congress has given us
maximum employment and stable prices we
are committed to making the best
decisions we can based on facts and
objective analysis today we decided to
lower interest rates as I will explain
shortly
we took this step to help keep the US
economy strong in the face of some
notable developments and to provide
insurance against ongoing risks the US
economy has continued to perform well we
are into the 11th year of this economic
expansion and the baseline outlook
remains favorable the economy grew at a
two and a half percent pace in the first
half half of the year household spending
supported by a strong job market rising
incomes and solid consumer confidence
has been the key driver of growth in
contrast business investment and exports
have weakened amid falling manufacturing
output the main reasons appear to be
slower growth abroad and trade policy
developments to sources of uncertainty
that we've been monitoring all year
since the middle of last year global
growth the global growth outlook has
weakened notably in Europe and China
additionally a number of geopolitical
risks including brexit remain unresolved
trade policy tensions have waxed and
waned and elevated uncertainty is
weighing on u.s. investment and exports
our business contacts around the country
have been telling us that uncertainty
about trade policy has discouraged them
from investing in their businesses
business fixed investment posted a
modest decline in the second quarter and
recent indicators point to continued
softness even so with household spending
remaining on a solid footing and with
supportive financial conditions we
expect the economy to continue to expand
at a moderate rate as seen from FOMC
participants most recent projections the
median expectation for real GDP growth
remains near 2% this year and next
before edging down toward its estimated
longer-run value the job market remains
strong the unemployment rate has been
near half century lows for a year and a
half and job gains have remained solid
in recent months the pace of job gains
has eased this year but we had expected
some slowing after last year's strong
pace participation in the labor force by
people in their prime working years has
been increasing and wages have been
rising particularly for lower paying
jobs people who live and work in low and
middle income communities tell us that
many who have struggled to find work are
now getting opportunities to add new and
better chapters to their lives this
underscores for us the importance of
sustaining the expansion so that the
strong job market reaches more of those
left behind we expect the job market to
remain strong the meeting of
participants projections for the
unemployment rate remains below 4
percent over the next several years
inflation continues to run below our
symmetric 2 percent objective over the
12 months through July total PCE
inflation was 1.4 percent and core
inflation which excludes volatile food
and energy prices was 1.6 percent we
still expect inflation to rise to 2
percent the median projection is 1.9
percent this year in two percent in 2021
however inflation pressures clearly
remained muted and indicators of
longer-term inflation expectations are
at the lower end of their historical
ranges we're mindful that continued
below target inflation could lead to an
unwelcome downward slide in longer-term
inflation expectations overall as we say
in our post meeting statement we
continue to see sustained expansion of
economic activity strong labor market
conditions and inflation near our
symmetric 2 percent objective as most
likely while this has been our outlook
for quite some time our views about the
path of interest rates that will best
achieve these outcomes have changed
significantly over the past year as I
mentioned weakness in global growth and
trade policy uncertainty have weighed on
the economy and
was ongoing risks these factors in
conjunction with unit inflation
pressures have led us to shift our views
about appropriate monetary policy over
time toward a lower path for the federal
funds rate and this shift has supported
the outlook of course this is the role
of monetary policy to adjust interest
rates to maintain strong labor market
and keep inflation near our 2 percent
objective today's decision to lower the
federal funds rate target by a quarter
percent to 1.75 percent to 2 percent is
appropriate in light of the global
developments I mentioned as well as
muted inflation pressures since our last
meeting we've seen additional signs of
weakness abroad and a resurgence of
trade policy tensions including the
imposition of additional tariffs the Fed
has no role in the formulation of trade
policy but we do take into account
anything that could materially affect
the economy relative to our employment
and inflation goals the future course of
monetary policy will depend on how the
economy evolves and what developments
imply for the economic outlook and risks
to the outlook we've often said that
policy is not on a preset course and
that is certainly the case today as I've
noted the baseline economic outlook
remains positive the projections of
appropriate policies show that
participants generally anticipate only
modest changes in the federal funds rate
over the next couple of years
of course those views are merely
forecasts and as always will evolve with
the arrival of new information let me
say a few words about our have ever
monetary policy operations funding
pressures in money markets were elevated
this week and the effective federal
funds rate rose above the top of its
target range yesterday while these
issues are important for market
functioning and market participants they
have no implications for the economy or
the stance of monetary policy this
upward pressure emerged as funds flowed
from the private sector to the Treasury
to meet corporate tax payments and
settle purchases of Treasury securities
to counter these pressures we conducted
overnight repurchase operations
yesterday and again today these
temporary operations were effect
relieving funding pressures and we
expect the federal funds rate to move
back into the target range in addition
as we've done in the past we made a
technical adjustment to the interest
rate paid on required and excess reserve
balances setting it 20 basis points
below the top of the target range for
the federal funds rate in a related
action we also adjusted the rate on
overnight on the overnight repurchase
facility to five basis points below the
bottom of the target range we will
continue to monitor market developments
and we'll conduct operations as
necessary to foster trading in the
federal funds market at rates within the
target range consistent with our
decision earlier this year to continue
to implement monetary policy in an ample
reserves regime we will over time
provide a sufficient supply of reserves
so that frequent operations are not
required to summarize we are fully
committed to pursuing our goals of
maximum employment and stable prices as
the committee contemplates the future
path at the target range for the federal
funds rate it will continue to monitor
the implications of incoming information
for the economic outlook and will act as
appropriate to sustain the expansion
with a strong labor market and inflation
near its symmetric two percent objective
thanks I'll be happy to take your
questions